unter dem meeresgrund des atlantiks hat
einen geologie team jetzt eine super
überraschende und spektakuläre
entdeckung gemacht es handelt sich um
ein gigantisches unter series
wasserreservoir das meer süßwasser
enthält als der viktoria see in afrika
bekannt als der zweitgrößte süßwassersee
auf der erde
dieses gigantische wasserreservoir vor
der us küste könnte das größte weltweit
seien und die experten und expertinnen
vermuten sogar dass solche riesigen
wasserreservoire auch noch anderswo vor
den küsten dieser erde schlummern
könnten bisher jedoch noch unentdeckt
könnten diese vielleicht als wertvolle
trinkwasserressourcen dienen klicks
umsatz und fitschen gibt's täglich
faszinierendes seines videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen
das ist wirklich eine wahnsinns
entdeckung das riesige süßwasser
reservoir liegt vor der ostküste der usa
und reicht bis zu 90 kilometer ins meer
hinaus nach angaben der fachleute ist es
mindestens 350 kilometer breit dazu
heißt es in der aktuellen studie
das aktiv er reicht von der küste von
new jersey bis nach martha's vineyard
und höchstwahrscheinlich noch weit über
unser untersuchungsgebiet hinaus
insgesamt könnten dieses reservoir
unglaubliche 2800 kubikmeter wasser
enthalten und das ist mehr als das
volumen des viktoriasees und das ist
immerhin der zweitgrößte süßwassersee
der welt schon in den 70er jahren hatten
forschungsteams bei bohrungen erste
hinweise auf der süßwasser reservoir
unter dem meeresgrund gemacht denn
eigentlich hatten sie bei ihren
erkundungsbohrungen mit erdöl gerechnet
stattdessen aber stießen sie auf
süßwasser dazu die new yorker
wissenschaftlerin klosters sonne
wir wussten dass es dort unten an
einigen stellen süßwasser gibt aber wir
kannten weder das ausmaß noch die
verteilung und das ausmaß kann derzeit
noch gar nicht richtig abgeschätzt
werden
doch die fachleute rechnen hier mit
etwas wirklich großen in ihrer studie
gehen davon aus dass unter diesem teil
des atlantischen kontinentalschelfs mehr
grundwasser liegen könnte als in den
größten grundwasserreserven an land wo
aufgespürt werden konnten diese
unterirdischen süßwasservorkommen durch
elektromagnetische messungen denn
dadurch wird die elektrische
leitfähigkeit in den offshore sedimenten
bestimmt die wiederum von zwei faktoren
abhängig ist zum 1
von dem salzgehalt und zum anderen von
der porosität des puren was im klartext
bedeutet das also das süßwasser
reservoir in den messdaten als weniger
leitende schichten auf allen klar war
bislang nur dass der meeresgrund in
manchen küstenregionen des atlantiks
süßwasser einschlüsse enthält doch
experten expertin gingen bislang davon
aus dass diese eher vereinzelt auftreten
klar ist aber dass es sich tatsächlich
um nahezu reine süßwasser handelt
messungen konnten zeigen dass das wasser
in dem nun aufgespürten oder sei aber
auch weniger als ein promille salz
enthält je weiter man sich von der küste
entfernt umso salziger wird das aktive
weise allerdings dennoch ist liegt der
salzgehalt auch hier lediglich bei 15
promille zum vergleich normales
meerwasser weiß seine sanität also den
salzgehalt von rund 35 promille auf doch
wie gelangt das süßwasser unter dem
meeresgrund das us forschungsteam
vermutet dass es sich zum größten teil
um überreste aus der letzten eiszeit
handelt vor rund 20.000 jahren waren
viele teile von nordamerika und auch die
nun überfluteten bereiche mit dem
sogenannten llorenti eisschild bedeckt
doch dann kam es zu schmelzen der
gletscher und der meeresspiegel stieg an
die experten und expertinnen vermuten
dass bei diesem prozess teile des
schmelzwassers in senken eingeschlossen
wurden und bis heute unter dem
meeresgrund erhalten geblieben sind ein
weiterer kleiner teil des süßwassers
wird laut der expertin expertin aber
auch unterirdisch von der küste unter
den meeresgrund strömen
das us forschungsteam geht davon aus
dass es weitere unterseeische aktiv
ehren anderswo vor den küsten zu
entdecken gibt dies würde vor allem in
den trockenen regionen dieser erde neue
möglichkeiten bezüglich der
trinkwassergewinnung eröffnen dazu die
forscherin carracci wenn wir belegen
können dass es auch in anderen regionen
wie kalifornien australien dem mittleren
osten oder in den süden afrikas solche
großen aktiv ehre gibt dann wären sie
eine wertvolle ressource klasse könnte
das auch zum beispiel für deutschland
sein denn hier sind wir mit einem
vollkommen neuen phänomen konfrontiert
wird das trinkwasser in deutschland
knapp folgen der hitzewelle sommer 2009
10 anklicken anschauen und klicks um
nature den neuen kanal rund um natur und
umwelt abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran